if this isn't said my career is a
youtuber I don't know what does hi guys
welcome to fry diary if I Diaries a look
back at all the things that happen to me
this week so let's start looking back at
the things that happened go me editor
put the clips in so this is my Saturday
right now is Wendy's probably putting a
doughnut to my forehead throw one a real
100 chicks that you guys get and don't
know about yeah well know about soon but
trust me everything professionally is
involved yes it's gonna be my tinder
profile picture this is a new fun game
goose place I'm petting great yes we're
petting and we're pitting and they take
my hand away how dare you just be
adorable as anybody camera lets you
shall do it now okay we're petting
preparing yes good job and good job
oh my god you were just clawing at me
when the camera was off okay let's
pretend the camera goes off hit it oh I
just turned the camera off
oh there you go who'd you do morning
guys it is Monday morning and today is a
very exciting day I'm going to the
graceshow house and it's finally all
done and decorated and ready for filming
the first episode this week so all of
the the team has seen it and I haven't
yet so I feel like I'm on one of those
home makeover shows on HGTV if ty
pennington is there with the bullhorn
I'm gonna lose my goddamn mind okay
let's go we just went through a run
through the first episode it's really
excited but I wanted to show you the
house look you walk in and there's oh
whoa well very tumblr those ladders
aren't there
the only there are the practicality look
it comes with crew guys yay yay then you
come in this room and look it comes with
more crew and there's James James is
responsible for the whole all of these
shenanigans and there's Blake Blake is
the director head boss guy these are
stickers stickers on a wall this is
witchcraft whoa the moon here we love
science here whole wall of selfies like
all these selfies and it's like you guys
know these people there's Nicki there's
Hannah there's Tim this thing keeps you
guessing and then this is the best thing
of all time look at this
big table and James made it how dare you
James it's his baby and then come look
at this pair of wooden emojis what and
an organ that works because we're going
to take you to church but look at this
the best show ever
why's it so cute now come look in the in
the kitchen in the kitchen there's an
entire chalkboard wall very college much
a dorm and then look at this in this
kitchen this is the wallpaper it's honey
but it's it's real honey packets on the
wall
what white what it's all such a mystery
besides you like you son hate it made me
really artistic you guys and there's no
going back
so deal with that hair makeup is done
can you tell yeah you can big time
welcome to the wardrobe room look at
that so fancy and here's oh look at this
is the pretty committee right here
Britney Wendy this event and look at
Britney Wendy space they get the master
suite well complete with Wow
watch this yeah that's what everyone
wants an unused jacuzzi tub let's see
the other room ready
look that's there good it's official
this is the green room that all the
guests get to hang in look
Wow Wow we're doing a run-through of the
opening it's like it's real that's Dave
yeah
he holds the camera silently judges
everyone that's John overall nice guy
and that's the moon so done and done
let's do it yeah we just finished the
interview with Aisha hell do you feel
about it
it was great Grace's how are you and
lovely she smells nice which is a great
interview our house is 105 degrees
sweating in here like a Swedish so
enough yeah there's a perspiration
running down the crack of my ass but
other than that was really super fun me
and every patient was all I heard was
smells good
so I'll take it thank you Aisha hello it
is what does it Wednesday night we've
officially shot the first episode of the
grace Helbig show are you gonna watch
uh-huh yeah what can you say about the
grace of a show you're not what are you
- oh there's dogs down there I was like
from this angle that looks real
compromise how would you describe the
grace Helbig show oh it's just it's full
got it perfect
Friday 10:30 on E following the soup I
feel very very good about it I feel V
confident guys V Kaka morning it is okay
Thursday morning yeah Thursday morning
here with Wendy and Brittany David yeah
you just look like Sun like KTLA this
morning so they've come to my house at
6:00 a.m. to make me look like it's not
6:00 a.m.
hey guys so I got done doing KTLA this
morning which was great and a lot of
energy for very early in the morning I'm
just leaving the graceshow house I went
over and got to watch the first cut of
the first episode and it's so good I
really really like it I don't normally
say that I like the stuff that I do out
loud very much to you unless it's like
something I really really like and I
really really like it it's only gonna
get better with more edits now I had to
rush home and put back on the clothes I
had on this morning because I've changed
into a memory heart whoo or better
sweatshirt
I could put a dress on and not to go to
a place with a lawn and like 100 media
people and talk to them more about the
show and get them to write quotes about
the things I say about the show in their
publication so other people think the
show is cool too guys the show is cool
there's your crush
there you are Ken my house welcome to my
house guy having a garden party
there's Ken just constantly trying to
get out of these videos on books this
looks beautiful you guys look great this
is what radio looks like just so
everyone sees hi guys I am home
and I've instantly changed back into
sweats
6:15 this is six hours of interviews
walking and talking in conversation just
sitting here huh counting down the hours
until the premiere and just sort of
sinking in the feeling that this is
happening and then keeping myself from
falling too deeply into it and keeping
myself this sign so that I never have an
identity crisis I hear dogs
hello okay bye she's going to go
probably take a dump here something her
mom doesn't take a dump on television
Friday night I have a 6 a.m. radio
interview shenanigans set up for
tomorrow morning so I'm going to work on
things and stuff and eat food I'm gonna
order food yes and I'm gonna do some
internet shopping that means I'm just
gonna open up a series of tabs of
different websites that sell things put
some stuff in carts and then close the
tabs oh yeah good morning it's no
morning it's 12:30 in the afternoon
today's the day it's the premiere of the
show tonight
I didn't sleep too much last night I had
to wake up for radio interviews this
morning at six am did them and then fell
back asleep for four hours and then the
bed did my hair this morning booty I'm a
little stressed out I'm very excited I
dealt with my stress last night by
putting these puffball string things on
the wall everyone has to channel their
stress into something some people stress
punch I stress craft very mediocre ly
now I'm gonna go for a stress run
because I've eaten a million stress
cookies and I have to get ready to go to
the soup in three hours so let's do that
otherwise I don't know if I'll fit I'm
gonna try and edit this before the soup
so it's not before the show so make sure
that tonight at 10:30 p.m. on a
following the soup you watch the grace
Helbig show yeah tell him goose speaks
for itself
really truly I've also been wearing this
sweatshirt from here we pray so thank
you guys in advance for all of your
support and I really hope you like this
show I really do that's the thing it's
like I really want to impress you
hashtag team internet I don't know